اذا مشاهدينا بعد انهيار سيليكون فالي
ترقب لفرملت اسعار الفائده وخسائر الاسواق
بالمليارات وتوقعات متباينه حول تخلي
الفيدرالي الامريكيه عن خطته خلال شهر
مارس مارس الماضيه على ان يعيد العمل به
لاحقا فقدت الاسهم الماليه العالميه
465 مليار دولار من قيمتها السوقيه خلال
ثلاثه ايام مع خفض المستثمرين لانكشافهم
على المصارف عقب انهيار بنك سيليكونزالي
لكن هذا السقوط المفاجئ بوقت قياسي لمصرف
سيليكون فالي في اقل من اسبوع فتحت باب
مخاوف من تكرار سيناريو عام 2008 الاداره
الامريكيه سارعت لمحاوله تهدئه المودعين
والمستثمرين على سلامه القطاع البنكي واجل
اجل طبعا المركزيه الامريكيه رفع سعر
الفائده لامتصاص
الانهيار وتفادي عوده التضخم لكن الخسائر
كانت فادحه وانعكست تدهورا للبورصات
وسقوطا حرا لاسهم القطاع البنكي في
البورصتين الامريكيه والاوروبيه في
المقابل مشاهدينا بعيدا عن التعقيقات
الاقتصاديه هناك بعض النصائح البسيطه التي
يستفيد منها طبعا العامه فيما يتعلق
باسعار الفائده وتجنب الاضرار الماديه
خلال الازمات الماليه فلنتابع
[موسيقى]